you suggest anything you want what are
the top of Khafre as long as it divides
those three rules what's that fake-ass
that's what most people have down here
thank you for doing a survey all the way
in just how do you tell they will pass
you just give it a little slap you go
that's that's a fake ass fake gas there
I love it what a great first gesture to
fake asses the first suggestion let's
come to this slide then to the second
one fake boobs I feel will will lump
that in with fake outz because I assume
they're made out of the same the same
material fake have some fake boobs good
good what was that Schrodinger's cat oh
my gosh okay well you've taken the cat
thing I'm gonna have I'm already
stepping out from fake outz and fake
booze to metaphysical physics problems
what was that ball hairs football hair
yes thank you
i pluralized him for some reason that's
because when I started throwing them I
literally counted I was so proud I was
like that's one ball hair and two ball
hairs thank you as more one time I
remember when it was very prepubescent I
saw one fall out I was like I'm gonna
get some glue and I cannot afford to
lose those obviously I didn't that's
comedy right fake ass fake boobs
Schrodinger's cat ball how was that tree
sloth fair enough
he's an animal in invert one is an
interesting one and one final one the
polar vortex the polar vortex sadly last
week when I was a it was suggested that
content sent suggestion twice so I'm
very sorry about that but I did record
it and it is on YouTube so you can see
them all is that what Pythagorean
theorem alright and you said it with a
point as well just like yeah trying that
one
you thought you have it easy with ball
hair fake boobs fake ass Schrodinger's
cat
now Pythagorean theorem was there did I
just miss one or another Superman no oh
whoa oh yes re-entry slot oh no we've
got five enough I mean suggestions not
commish rooms although I'm pretty sure
there aren't any this they're lovely
people at the most of each company magic
club is gonna be a little thing called a
freestyle rap that is a wrap I know yet
most people say that is a wrap based in
town on those suggestions made up
entirely on the spot it's never been
before before you'll never informed
again you'll be entirely about fake
boobs fake ass ball hair trees love
Pythagorean theorem in Schrodinger's cat
and do not worry it will not be anywhere
near as atrociously embarrassingly bad
as you're expecting a 29 year old middle
class privately educated white British
pointed me that beefy sir
maybe love it laughs to me alone
I'm excited I always cut a line here cut
attached and another plastic surgeons
queue looking for the axis a letter
judge them from far away from a bigger
gluteus maximus I've never seen ten take
a walk up and given the old rap and then
they turn round up like oh sorry exactly
why did you think that you need to
improve your muscle may be kicking how
high like in an audience oh that was a
fashion where they made them up live
it's like if you were beating yourself
stop in the loop like in the lift and
then they take care and move it high yet
put the silicon up there here I've got
licked but not Brazilian
that's download this one is in the
cotton they make him they get those nice
double D's or maybe go bigger for the MC
Jesus I can't believe I'm like jeez a
breast enlargement I see that yes but
you know I would rather have a real one
yeah I'm not hating I'm just saying that
it's just frustrating that could feel
this in a pack off the shelf admittedly
there's only one pair that I felt and
also it might not be my wife's
if my appeal may be the village dyke
next in ah yes or no is the cat a life
that's the answer that they go where
Albert Road dinner oh yeah you're the
only person who really even cares
everybody ever
what is it is some real problem in
theoretical physics easy degree for a
cat in a box of books of uranium in keep
it under lock essentially the question
is if they can live if there's an old
timer
now at the time these businesses are
lovin it they are really buzzing if you
are so sick put the cat in an oven that
we know is two boxes of the hot [ __ ]
yeah I thought it'd get a triangle and
say please get we all amuse a squared B
squared C squared
[Music]
[Applause]
maybe new atmosphere that's your lesson
now we've gotta take it slow from the
big tree stop I see you back there
elbows knees on a tree bow with his
three toes who tell them they're up like
he's in a gang member
whispered tree sloth that's how I
remember
[Applause]
that thing the last thing I am aware it
was cold in the port the vortex from
Nepal have a board outside leaving extra
layers I was born here and I'm in Nepal
like a player people were to me they
said look at the molecules in the
physics equation yeah all the follicles
are so damn long I would like to bring
it in and say although one for my hairs
or ginger it's weird
why are they a different color it
doesn't make sense I caught sight of my
brother and said yo explain to me bro
you've got so much hair looks like an
afro on your balls down on your testes
would I like some ball ball hair yes
please
[Applause]